[Music]
in
unboard news emitted by high oacute a
woman is seeking divorce because her
husband loves her too much and doesn't
argue with her husband doesn't argue
yeah dan that's Oh crazy good I need to
leave because listening to a podcast on
the way to work today it's a little car
right here and what they were saying so
like there's a ratio of a perfect
balance between getting enough fighting
in so you get a challenge and making you
want to stay so if there's too much
fighting and not enough benefits and
love then of course you want to leave
right but if there's too much perfection
and there's not enough of that like
eleven to one difference like one thing
good I mean one thing one thing that's
kind of off but like all these other
things are great then they're like I'm
bored
cuz then it's like you can't have a
relationship with all just positive all
the place no passion that's the ratio
love it's one they were doing a survey
yeah what typically what is the perfect
like ratio for this and this is kind of
like a relationship psychology thing and
then they're saying how like a lot of
people have this imagery of like happily
ever after right like they want they all
want this like perfect utopian
relationship where it's never anything
wrong and it's just fun fun and just
keep going up this way but in reality if
that happens then there's no challenge
and people just want to split because
it's just too perfect so this kind of
brings back that what I was listening to
yeah so uh yeah in Saudi Arabia this
wife is seeking a divorce a divorce out
there yeah every time yeah so he said
she said that he never yelled at her or
turned her down she was choked by
extreme love and affection even
she even helped her clean that house
what
there were no disputes in their
year-long American here what if she's
like why don't you beat me from time to
time what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
girls being yeah like just getting bored
yeah like she's trying to study that
also probably stems from a place of like
not natural compatibility or enjoyment
of each other's time
you know it's new day just like got
together oh this works but it's not like
I really love this pretty girl there
have to be some button-pushing in order
to have like that spark that makes more
ravages to are you guys like happy
relationships I shouldn't be talking
here what's up you guys tell us what's
the ratio you got no man not no man's no
pokey man's you know what this sounds
like
it sounds like she wants someone that
isn't a servant but like a husband like
an equal yeah yeah and it sounds like
he's doing everything far beyond it's
kind of like that guy like I think the
ladies have experience here where you
get with someone and then you think he's
cool but then he's like that obsessive
weird let me please you for every guy
like but it's to the point where like
you feel like he's your court jester
yeah and like he's not like your equal
right and then so then he does
everything but then too much too fast
and you're like yeah dated this one guy
who didn't have his own opinions he just
agree with everything I said I want to
be your perfect image of yeah exactly
what you said I agree I'm like I just
gave you a whole dissection of this
movie they're like how I felt about
different parts of it and you just agree
he goes same link Lee
yeah no opinion so like there has to be
some like Steve and I at least like
he'll have a different opinion sometimes
and I'm like oh that's interesting I
didn't even think of that
yeah if you'll fight for the most random
thing II will not let go the word I
think of when you guys thought about is
beta use that word all the time probably
overuse it yeah how did they use that in
the gaming community if you don't like
so much
he's a beta you're a beta you're like a
little bit you guys are but yeah you're
like a winner you're like alpha right
yeah what about Omega Omega I just made
a joke cuz that's alpha beta Omega sound
like another thing so hard to tell her
like an asexual yeah something like that
but but then look so like it's weird cuz
like Steve is a good balance for me
because I feel like he's stimulates me
he likes to argue he's like very debate
person I sometimes do too much but but
then he also is like I'm obsessed with
you you're beautiful I love you I'll do
anything don't worry I'll clean whatever
and I'm like wow he loves me but also we
can fight and I think that's when guys
will they'll all make the same mistake
of like loving too much or obsessing too
hard and and and being the insecure is
what's really spilling out right and
then they'll go they'll get jaded and go
oh you can't be too good to a woman and
then you turn into the other part where
like my girls like all these jerks
because then they're always staying with
these jerks unappreciative for sure like
if he was doing all the compliments and
all the cleaning and stuff and I was
like yeah so like then yeah I could see
you becoming jaded but yeah so this
woman here she was saying that her life
turned into hell because the man was so
kind to her she said I longed for one
day of disputes but this seems
impossible with my romantic husband who
always forgave me and showered me with
gifts I need a real discussion even an
argument not this hassle-free life of
obedience see she's just not explaining
herself in the way that makes her look
that's what I look that's what I thought
I found I was like I hope she's not I'm
just gonna give her the benefit of the
doubt cuz yeah so then they continue on
the article saying that the husband said
you did nothing wrong that he said I
wish to be a perfect and kind husband
almost and they also mentioned how one
time she complained about his weight so
he wanted a strict diet and exercise
Thank You shape she just sounds like me
but then he'll she's like pushing him so
that he can like react yeah something
please give me something so she's doing
a bad job at it because she has to find
what his insecurities are what if he's
just a really cool ass dude that's down
to like make people happy yeah sounds
like it I mean I feel like everyone for
him yeah I mean for her yeah everyone
has something but if it's a person like
how this guy's saying like I'm just
trying to be perfect and kind then
that's just like being fake there's no
everyone has [ __ ] flaws it's like
just [ __ ] show your flaws man like
obviously she wants actually bored as
[ __ ] I'd marry him well yeah so then he
they ended up saying that he said that
it's not fair to judge a marriage from
the first year and everybody learns from
the mistake so he wants a chance at
reconciliation he's like oh Lord
what's with you you are you stay hot
what if you're to just being the [ __ ]
out of her now he's like just what you
want [ __ ] you know how they say like we
try to recreate our childhoods and stuff
like what if she was from a [ __ ] up
ass childhood did you have any best [ __ ]
yeah we are people who are like this is
how you show love by like caring enough
to argue mm-hmm so sad maybe show me
that you love me by cheating on me what
kind of you know make your relationships
last one was like really good at the
beginning and then legit just work like
just too busy with work and also I feel
like I in the same or different feel ah
kind of in the same field I live in a
space early the community that I'm in
like your life your work is your life
like if you stream you stream like all
freaking day yeah everything you do more
or less revolves around streaming so I
tend to find that people like don't
always have a lot of relationship
experience or don't know how to balance
it they either just like drop their
stream and just focus on relations oh
they still like say soup stay super
strict with like their career and like
don't give enough to relationships
especially long-term you see that a lot
that sounds hard to be there because
gaming has there ever been that oh yeah
dad that might even upgrade y'all likes
a lot of people do that to you and
sometimes it works out party you don't
build relationships like that like
gaming no like um so like me and her and
like one of the products that we had is
that we have we do a lot of things
together for work but that doesn't count
as the relationship building time you
know just because we work together all
day or in the presence of each other
that does nothing for the release yeah
you have a separate date night yeah yeah
I I think a lot of people just like
don't realize that and like managing not
just relationships but your life and
then growing as a person 20 21 22 you
know you have a lot of growing to do to
even learn how to like be a good part of
a relationship you're so wise who are
you know but I really recognize that I'm
like we still got along really well um
and I mean I don't need to talk about
relationships publicly but in general
it's like usually just split up because
you realize like yeah we both got [ __ ]
toward God I mean if I was 20 done my
good so you
that was yesterday such a baby like that
we got like other people like that super
like though we check but even like this
it sounds like maybe she didn't realize
what kind of relationship she it sounds
like maybe an arranged marriage or
something like it like they got to know
who each other was in that marriage
where if you slapped her around in the
beginning oh I like this but then after
they got together he's like you think
now no slaps later ships are complicated
they're so calm because you need a it's
it's like what was the word it's like
you mold into another person through
this experience right so yeah you're
you're independent and you come in but
then you never come out the same way
kind of unit yeah well you know what's
crazy is before you even start the
relationship with someone else you have
a relationship with yourself that you
don't even know that you have until like
problems start surfacing in your like
the pop why is it everyone else's fault
and then you start looking in within
yourself and you're like oh my god it's
it's a relationship with yourself first
and then with someone else and then the
relationship you guys it's it's hard
what's kind of weird too is that there's
this whole mom what I don't know how to
call it but it's almost like guys that
get burnt they there's this whole
movement like they get burnt they're
like in their middle age and then they
get divorced and then they're all there
telling it's called like men going their
way
yeah and then they'll be telling the
younger guys like don't get into
relationships don't you know woman's
gonna take everything and then you have
the other side of the spectrum which is
like a lot of women that are like oh you
know guys are all bad they're all this
they're all sexes and then it's kind of
this weird generate
male dynamic yeah is not necessarily
crumbling but it's it's not defined at
all nowadays you know you go back like
few generations and it's like well women
usually do this and then usually do this
and not that it has to be that way but I
think most people kind of understood
what a relationship should look like and
now it's like basically whatever you
want it to be yeah like even open
relationships or whatever like a
relationship is literally harder because
it's like if you're a CEO you know we're
supposed to do for a janitor you're
supposed to do but then now it's like oh
you're a janitor you can run the company
if you want and you see the CEO you can
wash the toilet and then everyone
college is doing like should I not be
doing the extreme freedom though it
takes two strong yes like wise [ __ ]
centered individuals to come together
and be like what are our rules which no
one can do and I think that's why
everyone's splitting up and [ __ ] up
no no yourself yet that's why like I'm
trying not really to jump in anything so
I realized most the people I come across
it's like there's still figuring [ __ ]
out to me I gotta figure to that's why
I'm always fighting for traditional
gender roles I'm always fighting for
that alright you went there
[Music]